So good afternoon everyone. You are here
to learn how properly connected data can
help law enforcement agencies to disrupt
criminal networks. whether it is
fighting drug trafficking or country
terrorism or funding missing children or
um addressing any other security
challenge. And um uh today in particular
you will discover how knowledge graphs
and recently LLMs are literally
revolutionizing
law enforcement intelligence practice
and um I'll walk you through the journey
our customers have taken in adopting
this transformative technology. But
before doing that, let me quickly
introduce uh the company I work for
because as Pago said, I'm the graphab
chief scientist and for the last eight
years, we have been empowering law
enforcement agencies around the world um
to solve crime faster and more
efficiently u by using graph technology
solution. Our flagshiping product called
um YUM offers provides mission critical
analytics on top of knowledge graphs. So
some of the snapshots that you will see
today are um coming from from it.
Nevertheless, what I'm going to present
to you today is valid with or without uh
Yum. I'd like to start this presentation
from the end uh from the impact that
such a technology can have on people
because uh this isn't just about the
technology is about people life. She is
Sara and um while her name and her
picture are clearly generated her story
is definitely real. She represents
countless minors that um have been saved
from harm because a knowledge graph
system was able to detect a criminal
pattern earlier. In this case, a sexual
offender was found close to an a related
minor in a proximity of a restricted
area like a like a school. Before the
introduction of our knowledge graph
system um for this specific customer,
these type of uh patterns could take up
to 11 months to surface with a
consequence that you can all images
after the introduction of Yume. In this
case, these type of patterns can trigger
an alert almost in real time or the day
after. So the knowledge graph system was
able to convert incident reports or
policy reports and other data in
actionable knowledge saving definitely
many many lives. So um this is a I mean
this example is one just one of the
different challenges that these police
forces have to face every every day. So
let's uh deep dive into these challenges
actually. So these are a few sentences
from leading police uh policing journals
but they resonate very well with what we
hear again and again during our
discussions with um our customers
prospects and also industry uh peers.
Actually um these are challenges related
to data management legacy um software or
limited capability of collecting uh
properly uh data and these are
challenges that are really common across
all the type of police forces all the
type of law enforcement agencies
worldwide. But let's see from where
these challenges are coming. Starting
from the most common one as you can
imagine the data challenge because um
nowadays analysts are dealing with an
enormous amount of data most likely as
never before. They are often um struggle
to find the right information quick
enough to make a difference to solve uh
cases. Moreover, this data is not just
huge. Um, it is also disagregated,
disconnected and scattered across
multiple data uh sources each with
different schema, different access
pattern, different access rights and
this lack of integration make it
difficult for them to compose a
comprehensive uh picture of the crime
for example. Moreover, much of this data
is unstructured. Um, think of policy
report, intelligence report, witness
statement, but also videos, file,
images, logs, etc. And unfortunately,
much of this data is incomplete, wrong
or even worse um contradictory making
the analyst job so um hard. And that's
why data challenge or data challenges
lead directly to the analyst uh pains
because analysts are spending a
significant amount of time um searching
across multiple data sources. They often
find themselves um coming across
spreadsheets databases intelligence
report trying to collect information
about people, about vehicles um about um
other critical information that they
need to compose or to stitch trying to
stitch together a comprehensive um
narrative. Their work is not only um
let's say time consuming, it is also um
it is also repetitive and error pruning
because they often perform the same type
of search, the same type of comparisons
that will be easy to do if they had a
proper data management uh system.
Moreover, the work is also complex
because it's not just about search, but
it's also about cross referencing all
these data because they search in
different spreadsheet and then they have
to match this to create this
comprehensive um picture to show and
then of course there are there are the
managers pain because law enforcement
managers all around the globe are facing
significant resource constraints. they
um don't have enough staff to handle all
the the workload and um this is not
going to improve unfortunately. So um
keeping efficiency is not just or
improving efficiency is not just um a
nice to have is mandatory and moreover
uh these managers lack of comprehensive
visibility on the on the data making it
difficult to make let's say informed
decision in properly allocating
resources and managing their uh people.
Imagine that you have to deal with
citywide operation within partial or
incomplete or disjoint information. That
would be hard, right? So
for let's say fortunately not all is
lost because the fact that it was
working like this doesn't mean that it
must continue like this as a as a
practitioners actually we have the
obligation to find better ways. And um
out there there are several tools that
actually um I'm at improving the way in
which analysts perform their uh their
work and many of these tools actually
integrate graph and knowledge graph as a
powerful visualization tools. But the
type of mental shift I'm speaking about
is something that goes beyond the use of
knowledge graph as a visualization tool.
In the mental shift that I referring to,
the knowledge graphs represent
foundational assets for these
organization because they um force them
to rethink the way in which the data is
aggregated, is organized, is analyzed
and also visualized. By embracing this
paradigm, they can literally create a
sort of unified current view of of
intelligence. On top of which it's
possible not only performing the
classical um analysts work but also um
perform high level insights abstraction
that could help both the analyst and law
enforcement managers. So let's start our
journey by um introducing a key uh
concept that is a knowledge graph. Of
course I will not give you too many
details because you know what I'm
speaking about. So knowledge graphs are
more than just a data structures. You
know um a knowledge graph is a data
model paradigm that allows us in a
simple way to represent real world
entities uh like people, vehicles etc.
um in a simple way as nodes and
relationships regardless what was the um
the data source from where they are um
coming from. Let's consider a typical
law enforcement scenario. We can have
data about people as you can imagine
offenders, victims, witnesses or uh also
associates. Then we can have information
from crimes uh from locations or about
vehicles or very specific type of
objects like uh weapons, drugs, guns,
etc. Traditionally all these
informations are spread across a variety
of data sources you know with little if
not no connection between um between
them making it difficult to create a
comprehensive narrative as I said with
introduction of a knowledge graph this
changes completely because in a
knowledge graph all these let's say real
world entities will become nodes and
they will be naturally interconnected.
So in our example, we will have a person
that is connected to the crimes that in
some way um he or she is related to.
Then these crimes can be connected to
locations related to crime scenes or
meeting points. And these locations can
be tied to vehicles that have been
spotted by traffic cameras nearby that
area in a certain amount of time close
to the to the crime time. And these
vehicles in turn can be connected to
other people of interest. So as you have
seen by storing them in a knowledge
graph the analyst can just follow these
information that have been stored
properly and get um you know a proper
narrative and uncover hidden patterns
that would be very difficult to um
discover um otherwise. And this was just
an example but I think that you spotted
what is the power of this solution. But
let me try to reinforce even more
because um a knowledge graph um offers
several type of advantages. So first of
all it um allows to have this flexible
data model where it's simple to um to
store this information and to connect
them and to merge them from from
different data sources. Moreover, a
knowledge graph um offer uh let's say
very uh powerful navigation patterns
because every single node and every
single relationship can be considered
the entry point of the analysis and then
the analyst can just follow the
connections
composing a comprehensive view of the
cases that he or she is is following.
Moreover,
once all this data um is in the graph,
actually it's possible to perform via
machine learning tools or graph
algorithms high level analysis that
involves even the entire graph
extracting a lot of insights that could
be powerful information for analysts as
well as law enforcement managers. So
supposing that um I did um an amazing
job and I convinced you that the
knowledge graph is the way. So you might
be wondering how comes that not all the
law enforcement agencies around the
world are using it already. Well, to be
honest, um even though this is so cool,
it's not a simple transition for many of
these organizations because uh in
reality, uh first of all, it is a
complex passage, a complex jump, I would
say. Um because it requires literally to
to change, um to rethink the way in
which these organization are collecting
the data, are organizing the data, are
dealing with the uh the visualization
etc. And this often requires visionary
managers. Then um of course without
proper guidance, tooling and training
the the c the learning curve could be
quite steep. You know it requires a lot
of effort and this could be overwhelming
for many of the people in this
organization. Moreover, let's say that
there is a cost consideration and I'm
not speaking about only the money that
is also huge factor for buying software
licenses etc. But I'm also speaking
about resources, effort, time required
by these organizations to introduce such
a a new technology. That's why I like to
to present often this this picture that
better represented the situation. You
know, they are so busy but really busy
that literally don't have time to um
let's say to dedicate um space for
learning something new, you know,
because spending time on these type of
technologies could mean less people
saved. for example. That's why after um
trying um and often succeeding um in
selling this idea to these
organizations, we came out with this um
proven process made by three steps. This
is an iterative process. So it allows us
to gradually um let's say integrate this
knowledge graph solution in in the
organizations in the law enforcement
organizations. Um as I said it is
iterative which means that after you run
through these three steps the first time
with a few goals in mind you can start
from scratch but at that point the
system is already in production it is
freeing their time so they are more
let's say inclined to um spend time on
on the next iteration and I have to say
that even though we have done this for
many years in the in the past years
actually recently something new happened
as you can imagine you know because the
generative AI and the LLMs disrupted in
the technology field and this of course
is not an exception. I have to say that
I firmly believe that this has been a
nice introduction in the space for
several reasons that maybe you've seen
already many many times but in the law
enforcement space these um advantages
can be summarized in my opinion in in
this way. First of all, LLMs allow us to
dealing with unstructured data. As you
can imagine, during the knowledge graph
building phase, actually LLM simplified
enormously this step that before
required NLP fine-tuning with a lot of
annotation that was overwhelming and
nobody wanted to do that. The second
aspect is of course related to extending
the personas because via the
introduction of uh natural language
let's say question answering system for
example you know or chat botting if you
prefer we can um get out of the analyst
desk and for example as we will see uh
later we can address police officers in
the street. And the third point is of
course that we can extract as many
insights as we want from the graph but
this could be hard to understand from
several people. So even here LLMs can
help us to convert this data um these
insights into something meaningful for
them easy to digest. So uh let's start
with our um with our steps. Um of course
the first step is literally the
transition to an holistic intelligence
data that um clearly is based on
knowledge graph. In this way we can
break data silos isolation that we
mentioned is one of the major issues
here and we are able to create this
unified view of of intelligence. This
step is generally made by several
subtasks. The first one as you can
imagine is the identification of a goal.
Well, I would say a couple of goals,
something that is meaningful at the
beginning, at least something that makes
sense for them. It's not so complicated
because we would like to shorten the
time to value because we will have other
iterations to get through other other
goals. At that point, once the goal is
clear, we can identify what are the data
sources from where we can take the
relevant data for accomplishing this
goal. And then uh we have all the
information to start crafting the first
um knowledge graph model. And then we
can perform the ingestion and the
mapping of the original data structure
in our nodes and relationships. And
clearly we have the post-processing
phase that apart from data cleaning and
wrangling. Um one of the most common
data postprocessing is entity
resolution. If you have seen Paco master
class yesterday, you know this is a very
common task to accomplish in this case
because we are talking about several
sources where the same entity can be
represented in multiple ways. So it's
very very critical. So um in this phase
I think that we should be very creative
I would say uh because as as I said much
of the data is unstructured. uh in the
case of images and video for example
what we like to do is to process the
images by extracting fingerprints of the
face then clusterize them and creating a
graph made by the fact that people
appear to be in the same picture and
this can get us a lot of information
about organizational structure for
example criminals etc and then of course
there is the usual um LLMs that address
the the text um part you know as I
mentioned
This is a a huge introduction because
this simplifies a lot because using the
pre-trained models we can extract a lot
of information already with almost no um
custom training and this find a perfect
match with the knowledge graph because
entities and relationships extracted
from the text can naturally be stored in
in a knowledge graph and also we can
extract other information like I don't
know classification of the sentences u
etc. Then the second step well the
second step is more about a mental shift
you know because these people these
analysts are used to perform searches to
find their stuff you know as I said
often they have these spreadsheets so
they perform a search here a search
there and then they have to perform
these matching manually most of the
cases with the introduction of a
knowledge graph system actually this
changes they can still use the search as
a starting point but then they can
literally navigate the graph following
the connections among them in this case
it's crucial to have a solution and Yume
has um you know that allows them to
navigate the the graph. So the the
visualization should match one to one
the way in which this data is stored uh
literally so as a knowledge graph and um
search is just one of the options
because in theory as we have seen in the
Sarah's case it's important for them to
define a complex patterns so actually um
a properly set tool should offer
patternbased query that would avoid
these users to use cipher to perform
queries and we will see an example later
on. And then of course we have let's say
a plethora of graph algorithms, machine
learning tools that allow us to perform
um let's say um different type of
analysis. But here we can also store
procedures as in any other system to
allow them to um perform let's say
several type of operation again and
again in a simple way. And since the
graph is rarely static, it's important
for them to navigate through temporal
evolution. And of course due to the
specificity of the type of exercise,
it's important also to offer some some
maps. That's why we have here a few
examples on the left. On the bottom
left, you can see an example of our um
query pattern um builder um that allows
them to create their pattern, put some
filters and then convert it in a cpher
query. We have an example of navigation
and an example of course of a on a of a
map. Then uh again there is the LLM.
Here we are conducting some experiments
because as I said we would like to reach
the uh police officers in the street.
Imagine for a second that these police
officers are driving a car and they can
ask a complex questions like okay where
this car plate has been seen in the last
few hours for example you know uh it
would be super powerful that's where we
are going here and actually the graph
offer the right data set for answering
these complex questions. So now we are
using LLMs for a specific task actually
many tasks related to the conversion
from the question in natural uterance
let's say into
cipher query but also to extract intent
to recognize the portion of the
knowledge graph that we should
investigate and we have also some other
techniques like query validation and
also we offer to the end user the
reasoning so that um he or she can
verify that the results are fine in this
case we don't have hallucination because
the data is coming from the graph. Um so
there is no issue related to the
generation of results that are not true
because in any case they are coming from
a curated knowledge knowledge graph.
Then we have the last step. Last step is
is is really related to the to the to
what come next. You know we would like
to migrate from a reactive approach to a
proactive approach. So in this case um
we are migrating from analytics to
predictive uh policing by using the
graph algorithms and other tools we can
literally process a huge amount of data
and extract a lot of insights. So here
we configure this step as any other data
science project. So the first subtask is
to define a goal then to perform some
data preparation and we will see a
couple of examples and then you have as
I said a pleator or graph algorithms
that you can run in sequence or in
parallel um for extracting relevant
insights and get what you need even in
this case it's important to present the
data that the results of these analysis
in a in a proper uh way. So let's see a
couple of quick examples you know one
very very common example is the
co-fender network. So you start from um
say offender and crimes and then you can
create a co offender network by
connecting offenders because they have
committed a crime together and the
weight in this case is defined by the
the number of crimes that committed
together. So it's simple to verify how
once you have this type of portion of
the graph you can run lu vane or
whatever community detection algorithm
you like and you can easily recognize
criminal groups that could be related to
organized crime setup or gangs etc. But
it's easy to recognize and to analyze
also these type of patterns. Or you can
do something something else like you
know predicting links. So predicting who
will co-offend with with whom and this
is also very powerful to discover hidden
patterns in the um let's say in this
community of of criminals and there is
again even here something new that we
are exploring thanks to LLM because we
notice that we can extract tons of
insights from these data but this could
be overwhelming for whoever analysts or
law enforcement managers. So we run a
few experiments in which we started from
the coffender network that we have seen
before. We extracted a lot of
information out of it like uh with page
rank between the centrality we can
reveal key people inside the network. We
can then extract the list of crimes with
information about locations uh time etc.
you know that is quite overwhelming
specifically for large group of people
and and then we also processed the
entire data set actually extracting
statistics about the the crime settings
the area with I guess rate of criminals
etc and we passed all this information
to LLMs and I asked okay can you
generate a report for this specific
criminal organization and actually the
result is astonishing because not only
we've got a nice summary but actually um
this specific ific experiment run on
cloud eye was able to extract other
patterns related to time range or time
patterns in the execution. Moreover,
since it is able to convert latitude and
longitude in the specific areas, it was
able also to convert this information in
something meaningful for the law
enforcement uh space. So, and this is
just the beginning. I will say there is
a lot to investigate and to and to
discover. So um in um in order to get is
not working anymore.
Can you go to the next slide?
So in any case it's not an issue. So um
let's conclude this talk by um
highlighting the main um elements you
know the key elements so that this will
stick in your uh in your mind. So we
have seen how the the different
challenges that um the law enforcement
organizations are are facing are
actually connected in one way or the
other or the other to the way in which
these organization are dealing with
their data. You know um the way in which
they store it, the way in which they
manage it and these difficulties
literally translate in uh inefficiencies
with the consequences that this has on
um on on people. And then we have seen
this new uh approach let's say new for
them of course not for us um you know
made by knowledge graphs and LLM that
could really address all these
challenges make them more effective in
the future but these come with a cost
you know and they are busy people that's
why we created we crafted these three
steps and the iterative approach to
gradually let them um be introduced to
the knowledge graph word I will say and
I'd like really to conclude remembering
the Sarah's case because really this
isn't just about adopting a new
technology because it is cool you know
as in the example of Sara you know this
could literally translate in more lives
saved you know in a people life made
better and really with this sentence I'd
like to uh to thank you for listening
today and I'd love to hear your
question.
[applause]
>> Thank you very much. I can run to you.
>> Yeah, thank you. Really interesting
talk. Um I come from a mathematical
modeling background and one thing that
we discuss quite a lot and it's it's
coming into um AI now as well is ethics.
And um as data big data has grown
there's a real concern around just
because you can infer something doesn't
mean you should and one of the big
issues with predictive models is that
they don't live in isolation.
So you have the model and you have
reality and the model starts to drive
reality and um there's a a really good
book called the alignment problem that
talks about this issue of the effects
that models actually have on people's
lives and I completely agree with your
point about preventing harm but what are
you doing to make sure that these models
don't cause harm for example there are
lots of cases where algorith alorithms
have been used and caused over policing
um persecution
uh perpetuated or even um reinforced
bias.
>> Well, yeah, I mean this is definitely a
big problem you know and that's why
pitive policing is still not used widely
even because the early experiments
conducted in this sense were biased as
you know you know because of the type of
the data set that was used. I will say a
couple of things. Most of the examples
that we have seen today like SARS case
and whatever are rule based in the sense
that they are able to define a clear
let's say patterns that are just real
you know in the sense that the system
will reveal that certain type of things
defined by humans are verified in the
database. So there is a certain
certainty that this is relevant for them
and the data is easy verifiable. So you
can see that this is true and of course
there is a risk of overpolicing but uh
you know it's always a balance between
the two you know being overpoliced or
being safe. Um regarding predictive
specifically actually I would say that
the knowledge graphs are showing great
advantages in terms of explanability you
know over classical LLMs alone you know
that makes no sense by itself. So I
think that this is the way in which we
should spend our effort you know trying
to make at least the decisions that the
machines are doing clear or easier to
explain as much as possible so that a
human in the end will decide if it's a
go or no go. That's the only way that I
see for that.
>> I can I can beat you.
Thank you so much. This was fascinating.
Um from the uh how do you predict how
organized crime evolves? Do you guys
also use background models coming from
economics
uh in terms of naronomics for this
extent for example because there are
certain patterns that you can actually
foresee in terms of the evolution and um
you could I imagine insert them into
your graph. So you can kind of monitor
the early signals.
>> Well, that's definitely interesting. Not
yet, I would say. But uh this is a good
uh good suggestion actually. The problem
is always the data unfortunately you
know because uh there is a limited
availability of open source data that we
can use without being inside an
organization you know because we are
always outsiders. So it's difficult for
us to get in and see the real data. So
in the case that I showed we have used
this Chicago data set that is public
available but is very let's say limited.
So it's a very good idea. Unfortunately
data is our biggest enemy because we
can't get access to this data
unfortunately.
>> Yes. But perhaps if you have the model
you can get signals that you can start
to yeah
>> connect in a different way if you know
what you're looking for in terms of the
pattern.
>> That's true. That's true.
>> Okay. Interesting.
>> Quick question. Other
questions? We can also ask at break. I
think we've we're probably coming into
Yeah, we're into break now. So, um All
righty. We'll be back uh after the
lightning talks, but there's a break
right now. Thank you, Allesandro. Thank
you very much. Fantastic talk.